welcome to this video playing panopticon
plate him just very recently and we had
this yeah I remember we had the
Rubenstein I'm going to to go to the Z
me show ever check let's see
okay yeah this is a possibility squeaky
five just you for now on yeah i'm going
to start with you for 5 d 5 is a very
known stray well known structure way as
castled early what very often can go for
this kind of full-scale um expansion on
the on the Kings side with the f 3g form
and let's see 92f 3g 493 could be
something
yeah the night needs to go there anyway
e 2 is the best best square covering the
crucial dark squares and keeping options
open okay so no I'm actually okay can I
love play G for now he can he can play
Knight f4 and sacrifice a pawn but this
is not sufficient really yeah so we just
gifted me to moose I could have played
g5 though I this was was a bit quick
here my g3 but ok it's still still an
excellent position ok night f5 or or
just HOH forest good cover I cover for
so future age 5 he can only retreat
again or answer with this porn second
half form which really is not sufficient
he does not get a five for a long time
after that night f4 takes takes Queen
takes 95 it's not it's not sufficient I
can go night at five now actually attack
d 6 when here when he's leaving the c8
square for a six-night f5 gain sir
against lots of power ok so i can play
h5 if i want i can also get the second
route involved ok and just take a Kim
n95 can just go back okay this and then
h5 all let them take i guess i can i can
take myself and then go age five the
attacking plan is root d to g 1 and g 6
that's not not so easy to prevent really
if i go h 6 h-6 is also not bad g6
hmm I can take g7 as well but this is
probably not a direct win 93 years am is
a counter idea of course which I
shouldn't totally a tuille ignore and do
I really need to play a defensive moves
like book look at you one here yeah
maybe okay
number that i probably have played this
a bit too a bit too relaxed I mean what
is this was overwhelmingly better and
probably still is but I had I certainly
had some better continuations I'm quite
sure about it so let's consider if I go
age 6 g 6 is there is this winning
material at least like with night
Nigerian go look who gave it ok that's
not really convincing and something like
g6 is not a winning directly
and that's not not that great it's
really not that great this 93
counterplay was really really a problem
there is no there is no direct when
neither really isn't should I try to
maybe play a four get rid of the night
but then yes this counter play against
you form this isn't clear it's really
not time warning it's really not clear
58 seconds
tending 96 then I get to f6
58 okay is not much ahead timewise okay
i can now I can't get to this end game
which is quite quite good this is why I
was checking the time making sure that I
can actually play this end game and not
lose it on time you see five point is
sighs week and even he gives it up right
away okay 46 I should just check just
keep pushing let me assure come to g2
but I have counter I've mades on 88 so
he cannot easily use both rocks yeah
this is very good for white probably win
the D&AD pointless too much yeah it's
too much the pawns are too too strong
yeah but still I should have should have
put this away of our Liam check
this probably also wasn't very
convincing check check hmm not sure this
I have rooks e6 ok it is wearing resign
Luke c 6-r up yet ah I agree let him
back into the game around here this is
just when he just gifted me an already
bad line you gifted me two moves with
night h5 is this stuff right here this
is basically a winning position for
white but i didn't i didn't really put
it away very convincingly hmm I wonder
maybe King f2 really was was a lemon
the computer suggestion is really very
very strong yeah sometimes it's just
when you see the move you see how strong
it is he wants to play not this it runs
to play h5 clear this is an easy move to
see but the thing is what is really
strong after night f form the computer
just wants to retreat to have one and
that's really strong black is basically
a left without this 95 counterplay
business and here really want what is
humans now it's a big problem we cannot
go here as d6 hangs and what exactly are
you doing wow that's really strong and
that's Queen edge to coming maybe g6
yeah that's fantastic for what that's
much much better than the game this was
really some counter play and now on this
was wasn't ready when you look do you
want a stronger yeah here I don't know
Queen g3 seems to be better according to
the computer okay now queen age to be
are difficult really difficult I was
probably not doing something totally
stupid but there was something better
before okay no F was strong but i didn't
i didn't see that check what I didn't
see is that really here Queen d4 it's a
very strong continuation yeah yeah
I understand yeah this is what the
computer is giving by the way with the
wide win this is a hair if this is quite
nice okay so this is what I played rukka
fade and now this should be good yeah it
is it is better for ID okay f6 knight c6
but 96 is strong right check and this is
really a good end game this leaf I this
week and the deep bone is very strong
probably probably this is winning
provide the compass on to point
something okay i hope you liked it
thanks for watching